vous aimeriez habiter le marais
pourquoi
parce que la vie est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simple
plus libre plus naturel
[Musique]
ça fait 14 ans
ah oui
il me plaît admirablement à tous les
points du point de vue tranquille
il était bien sûr il est tranquille 11
mois par an mais le 12e mois sous vos
fenêtres vous êtes au premier loge pour
une série de spectacle que je vous en
pensez bien je pense une chose je vous
le si vous voulez le décomposer
premièrement la question oui pour des
personnes qui travaillent c'est assez
ennuyeux
d'un bambouillard dormir le soir le haut
point de vue spectacle c'est très
intéressant
c'est très intéressant bien sûr mais
enfin en principe quand on voit le
spectacle on voit une pièce un soir on
ne la voit pas si c'est le soir de suite
pour vous Jean Vilar jouer Molière aux
marais que cela représente-t-il
bien que l'avare n'est pas été créée en
166 dans ce quartier ce quartier du
Marais est à l'origine non pas seulement
de l'architecture du 17e et 18e siècle
mais aussi de notre tragédie et de notre
comédie française puisque classique
française puisque j'ai à 100 ou 200
mètres d'ici qui a été joué pour la
première fois le site par exemple
oui jouer la VaR devant cette très belle
bâtisse et très belle façade de l'Hôtel
Des Rouen
qui date du début du 18e siècle le nom
du siècle de Louis XIV évidemment ça me
paraît pas paradoxal de toute façon le
public n'a jamais pensé que cette belle
demeure des Rohan appartenait à Monsieur
Harpagon en attendant qu'il
soit honneur de votre logis madame dans
le jardin où je ferai porter la
collation Valère Valère et un peu l’œil
surtout toujours tout ceci
parfois des musiques insolites des
chorégraphies avant-gardistes font
irruption dans ce monde de tradition
venu des États-Unis le Harnes ballet
donnait Ariane d'André Jolivet
au hasard du corps de ballet la grâce et
la gentillesse de Lily une Américaine de
20 ans
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que vous dansez
que vous venez à Paris les livres
[Musique]
vous savez pourquoi ça s'appelle le
marais
parce que
[Musique]
il y a des gens très célèbres qui ont
vécu ici vous en connaissez certains
[Musique]
de Paris
pourquoi ça s'appelle la place des
Vosges
non
décidé que le département français qui
aurait le premier fini de payer ses
impôts donnerait son nom à cette place
et c'était le département des Vosges
il fait bon la nuit tombée à flâner sur
la place des Vosges
au soir de festivals les boutiques ne
ferment que fort tard
[Musique]
on est bien la terrasse des cafés
le marais en temps de festival c'est
aussi la confrontation des vieilles
pierres et des réalisations les plus
modernes des projets les plus ambitieux
[Musique]
forme abstraites volontiers provoquant
forme innocents détournées de leur but
[Musique]
le mari sourit il en a vu d'autres lui
et ses vieux habitants
il y a longtemps que vous habitez le
quartier madame
1894 alors vous le connaissez bien
je connais mes poissons quand même
vous le connaissez bien mais est-ce que
vous l'aimez bien aussi
on est à tous ces souvenirs
actuellement c'est l'école maternelle et
l'école maternelle se trouve se trouvait
à la place de l'école professionnelle et
puis alors le 6 place des Vosges était
l'école des garçons et en 1902 on a fêté
le centenaire de Victor Hugo avec des
illuminations de toutes ces œuvres
autour de des grilles
et en 1905 il y a eu l'inauguration de
la Maison Victor Hugo aussi se passe des
Vosges on a supprimé cette partie là
pour les de l'école des garçons
ensuite il y a eu sur le
on a installé une scène devant le la
mise en Victor Hugo et Cécile serait la
déclamer les oeuvres Victor Hugo
le marin a vu d'autres il en a tant vu
que ses blessures sont innombrables
alors certains se disent pourquoi ne pas
le soigner et si en temps de festival
ils se font ouvreuses ou machinistes le
reste du temps il manie la pioche et la
pelle comme ça pour le plaisir puisque
la plupart d'entre eux n'habitent pas le
marais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous avez décidé à
consacrer vos loisirs la restauration de
ce quartier
je crois que la décision c'est venu
comme ça je suis venu à jour et ça me
plaisait je suis resté depuis deux ans
je suis là
qu'est-ce qui vous a plu le travail
qu'il s'agissait de venir à bien
l'ambiance d'une certaine équipe
l'ambiance d'un quartier quoi
un peu tout à la fois il est certain que
l'ambiance vaut la peine le travail
amené à bien et toujours une opération
intéressante
le fait d'être avec de jeunes qui en
valent qui qui sont prêts à consacrer
quelque chose qui croit et qui sont
prêts à réaliser quelque chose
la recherche pure et simple de
rechercher dans des caves dans des
vieilles maisons que ce soit les hôtels
ou simplement des maisons modestes qui
sont souvent beaucoup plus intéressantes
parce que justement pas connu
on les considère comme vraiment le
dernier des derniers quand on va dedans
qu'on part avec un peu d'amour pour
découvrir ces pierres on découvre des
tas de choses très intéressantes des
choses que on ignorer complètement
vous-même le premier mais la société
entière aussi vous aimeriez habiter le
marais
pourquoi
parce que la vie est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simple
plus libre plus naturel
et puis surtout dans une
dans un quartier de vieilles choses de
vieilles maisons c'est beaucoup plus
joli le marais le premier quartier ou en
Europe on a essayé d'organiser la vie de
la société dans sa construction
va pouvoir justement rentrer dans cette
ville à comprendre que comment est-ce
qu'ils avaient voulu ça et pourquoi et
comment et puis d'un autre côté de voir
comment ils habitaient enfin quand on
regarde une maison on voit que ici il y
avait ça là il y avait ça il y avait
ceci ce serait intéressant de voir
comment vivait nos ancêtres et pourquoi
il y avait comme ça qu'elles étaient
leurs raisons
c'est pas simplement une admiration si
vous voulez pour des caves gothiques ou
des voûtes magnifiques mais c'est de
rentrer dans l'un des gens qui
habitaient là et pourquoi ils évitent
comme ça qu'est-ce que vous avez trouvé
de plus que nous qu'on a perdu que nous
avons en plus et que nous pourrions
aménager enfin il y a une communication
avec le passé et tout ça en vue du futur
pour pouvoir justement aménager le
quartier et lui rendre une vie adaptée à
notre époque
parce qu'ils ont fini de piocher et de
brouetter il se réunissent ici dans ce
petit restaurant dans le patron venu
voici 15 ans de très loin de Colombes et
c'est l'expliquer ce que c'est d'habiter
le marais
j'ai arrêté dans un autre quartier
sera peut-être été pareil ici je me
considère chez moi parce que
je suis avec tout le monde
j'étais pas rare de
j'ai super dans le quartier qu'on m'a
demandé d'être parrain j'étais premier
témoin j'étais à des enterrements alors
c'est une espèce de famille quoi
c'est une espèce de famille
accueillante à ce venu de loin
partageant leur deuil et leur souffrance
[Musique]
faisons place à leur tradition à leur
nostalgie
[Musique]
c'est cela le marais un festival de
poésie de musique quand arrive juin
juillet
et le reste du temps un quartier au
charme indéfinissable
ce charme que voici plus de 300 ans
chantait déjà Scarron
[Musique]
adieu beau quartier des marais c'est
avec mille regrets qu'une très pressante
besogne pour quelques temps de vous
m'éloigne enfin tous ceux et toutes
celles en jouant saut que j'ouvre en sel
qui m'aimait et que j'aime aussi adieu
vous dit le cœur transi
[Musique]